welcome everyone and thank you for
attending the final panel of the
conference political lotteries the
future of democracy um so we decided to
end the conference with um this panel
that allows us um and the audience to
have a group brainstorm about some of
the benefits and the challenges of using
lotteries and also to tackle some bigger
questions so should we get rid of
Elections can deliberative institutions
scale up what should new areas of
research and collaboration be this is
also going to be the chance for you the
audience to ask um questions um and
engage with the presenters and feel free
to um ask as many questions as you'd
like and there will be individuals
around to pass you a mic so once we um
begin the open Q&A please look to Kira
in the back for a microphone um so we'll
begin with a half hour of prepared
questions and then open it up but first
i'm very pleased to introduce um your
panelists so on the far side Federica
carugati is a senior lecturer in history
and political economy at Kings College
London her research as you've seen
earlier in the conference focuses on two
topics the development of political
legal and Economic Institutions and
premodern citizen centered governments
and second the lessons that the
emergence configuration and breakdown of
such institutions hold for the theory
and practice of institution building in
the modern world she's the author of two
books a moral political economy present
past and future Cambridge University
press and creating a constitution law
democracy and growth in ancient anthens
from Princeton University press as well
as a number of Articles published in
academic and popular Outlets including
an article I love in
wired uh next to her is Dimitri Landa
who's a professor of politics at uh NYU
his research focuses on democratic
theory formal Theory and political
economy as well as philosophy and law
his recent research has focused on
studying deliberation and debate
including experimental and formal work
as to what extent the debate process is
informative to participants as well as
research on how to structure
deliberative activities of argumentation
information acquisition and learning um
most relatedly he's working on a book
manuscript with Ryan pevnick also at NYU
entitled representative democracy ad
justification um with Oxford University
press and this manuscript compares the
Electoral selection of policy-making
officials to Salient Alternatives many
of which we've talked about today such
as direct democracy Lottery based
systems and mccratic alternatives uh
next to Dimitri is uh Philip Lindsay who
leads the Democracy Innovation Hub at
the Hannah arent Center for politics and
Humanities at Bard College uh since 2022
The Hub has hosted two annual convenings
on citizens assemblies that bring
together elected officials Community
leaders Advocates and practitioners to
Workshop precisely how to scale
collaborative governance from a place
based perspective um The Hub also
recently hosted the doing democracy
differently teacher Fellowship which
trains High School teachers on how to
bring deliberative democracy into the
classroom he's co-founder of the
assembly project as we've heard about
earlier and helps coordinate the
energized New York initiative and last
but not least Chris Chris Rose is the
head of governance insights at meta
where he works across the company to
drive thought on emerging trends at the
intersection of Technology society and
governance prior to this role Chris
helped launched the company's oversight
board as well as serving as a
geopolitical Analyst at the CIA for a
decade
uh to include uh sment as the
president's Daily Brief briefer to then
US president Mike Pence and most re
recently served as the senior adviser at
the cyber security and infrastructure
security agency during the Biden
Administration Chris H is a master in
public policy from Georgetown and is a
team member also with the Council on
Foreign Relations so as you see we've
brought together a combination of
academics practitioners and folks from
industry to tackle these big questions
now I've given each of the panelists the
opportunity to have opening statements
to tell you the audience about their
current research or their current
activities and we'll start in the order
that I introduced to you so Federica
please okay is this good okay um so yeah
Ali asked uh to uh for us to give a
little bit of a brief I guess on the
research again I don't want to bore you
too much given that some of you at least
have been in the audience long enough to
know uh pretty much uh what my research
is about but just for the sake of uh the
recording I suppose um I am trained as a
historian by by ambition a political
scientist and I study premodern
governance particularly premodern uh
Democratic or Collective governance um
and after spending a um someone might
say too much time uh thinking about uh
governance in ancient Athens I decided
to broaden the scope of the
investigation to studying instances of
collective governance in the premodern
world uh they go beyond um Athens that
go beyond uh most recently uh Europe uh
with the uh hope that U broadening the
scope of the investigation on historical
Collective governance might give us uh
better more robust insights about what
Collective governance might look like
today and so the idea is not so much to
sort of like lose myself in uh
historical experiments or historical um
evidence but it is to bring that
evidence to conversations about building
Democratic spaces today particularly at
a time when uh democracy seems to be uh
not as
cool an experiment as we thought U maybe
a couple of decades ago or even less
than that um so again I think that just
to be uh relatively brief and clear I
think that there is a lot to learn about
historical Collective governance for
building a theory a more robust theory
of collective governance today but also
to really um uh provide uh additional
sort of like a Food For Thoughts for all
those communities many of which we have
discussed today there are trying to
build a collective governance space is
online and offline um and I think that
this is what my research is trying to do
although it is somehow uh and often
perhaps too often uh Dorking out on
things historical it is uh pretty much
uh inspired by a focus on practice and a
focus on applications uh in the
present great thank you fed
Dimitri okay
um um I work at the intersection of uh
political economy and political
philosophy and I want to
um in my remarks what I want to do is to
suggest a perspective on miniu and
biocratic governance that comes from
thinking about what political economic
models and in particular strategic
models of decision- making um tell us
about these things um and I'd like to
talk in particular about two sets of
political economy models models of
communication and models of Delegation
um a key result of uh the Strategic
models of communication many of which
focus on the scenario of committee
decision making committee deliberation
prior to Collective uh policy Choice um
is that participants willingness to
engage in a kind of open-ended
deliberation is critically conditioned
on their expectations of how their
speech might affect the ultimate
committee
decision um in essence these models
study the various ways in which a
participant's communication strategy
what to say how to interpret what others
say whether to speak or listen um are
sensitive to the details of the policy
selection rules after communication and
a key expectation here is that
participants behave in a relatively um
you know manipulative kind of way not as
ideal type participants in what ygen
haras called ideal speech situation or
Josh K and ideal deliberative uh
position um moving on to the Strategic
models of Delegation a key result here
is that by and large um strong
accountability incentives make for
tighter connection between the interests
of the participants um and uh um and and
the principles uh so in the interest of
in particular the the interest of the
principles voters and the um in the
choices those who are of those who are
making choices on their behalf which is
to say um politicians uh um members of U
uh legislative bodies or Executives
there are some exceptions to this um
such as pandering for example and
closely related to that perverse effect
of transparency but those exceptions um
have to do not with whether you want
accountability but whether you want
stricter or weaker incentives via the
accountability channels the bottom line
from these kinds of models is that
accountability via selection and
treatment mechanisms is how you make
your presentation work so now let's
think about the relation between these
expectations right from these uh you
know two sets of models strategic models
of communication and strategic models of
Delegation um and and and the way manyi
publics work so with respect to the
Strategic models of communication you
take away the binding policy choice and
you remove a key factor that is
responsible for manipulative
communicative posture that strategic
models of communication describe in
other words by taking away the binding
policy decision you remove a key
impediment to open-ended deliberative
exchange now there's a worry uh by
removing an extrinsic motivation um to
affect a certain kind of you know
binding policy outcome as a result of
communication you're also removing
incentives to uh make careful kind of
thought out decisions but I think um
what we see is that citizens juries
among other types of minipublics replace
extrinsic with intrinsic motivations
participants are Keen to be there and to
engage with each other of course this
leaves issues on the table with respect
to the relationship between the
distribution of intrinsic motivations
and the distribution of participants
prior beliefs their demographic
characteristics and so on but these are
arguably solvable kind of technical
issues and the stratification based
sample selection techniques are in fact
increasingly effective in solving them
if you now go back to the Strategic
models of Delegation that I described um
many publics give up accountability of
the represent presented and by doing so
they presumably rais the Spectre of
decision- making that does not represent
voters interests but because they don't
make binding policy decisions the worry
is much more attenuated um if what we
have in mind are consultative point of
information kind of bodies the concerns
with accountability are arguably not so
pressing so both sets of strategic
problems with communication and with
faithful representation appear to be at
least attenuated if not entirely
eliminated by the lottery base many
publics being deliberative but not
ultimately polic making bodies so here
comes the challenge right is this a
staple in the sense of equilibrium
outcome right are we improving in
refining the quality of many public and
as we are doing this are we not
increasing their attractiveness as
substitute policy makers or at least as
authoritative kind of deference
requiring decision makers this is not
the point about whether Scholars or
activists are seeking to use mini Publix
as substitutes or supplements of
existing institutions of law electoral
democracy rather this is a point about
the equilibrium Authority with which
recommendations of manyu um would be
endowed by the citizens which is to say
how the citizens themselves would
perceive mini publics the more reliable
and authoritative citizens perceive them
to be and so the more differential to
them the citizens would become the
stronger the incentives for the
participants to engage in manipulative
speech and to depart from faithful
representation become in other words the
more relevant the Strategic models of
communication and delegation become
um there's a further threat to the
stability of the normatively attractive
model of minu that relates to Ali's and
Brenda's work that we heard about today
the more influential the minipublics are
and the more parties want to control
them because ultimately parties are
multi-dimensional issue Aggregates and
they're constrained by considerations of
political fusibility in the way that
liberative minipublics are not parties
and other long-term decision actors
should then be naturally expected to
look for ways to co-opt and constrain
author dat of many publics to avoid
being left holding the bag so you can
think of the considerations I described
as a kind of paradox of Authority for
autocratic miniu the threat to the
authority of miniu is from there
becoming authoritative but it's if it is
a paradox it's not the kind that comes
with an absurd proposition since we can
readily make sense of it analytically um
whatever it is I think it raises a set
of important questions that is worth
thinking about whether
expectations um from the many existing
miniu experiments can be expected to
scale up and persist over a long run
what we can plausibly hope the roles of
miniu to be and you know in the long run
how enthusiastic about them ultimately
we should
be thank you Dimitri Phil go ahead that
was fascina I feel like I need five
minutes to just reflect on I don't know
if this is on
but um am I loud enough
I now it's there we go um
yeah that was fascinating to to Think
Through um and so my name is Philip
Lindsay I lead the Democracy Innovation
Hub at the Hana rent Center Bard College
um I found myself on the way up to the
Hanah rent Center to a conference they
were running before I joined two and a
half years ago um the Hana rent Center's
been running conferences for the past 15
years on different topics social media
um Civil Disobedience we br bring
together journalists activists uh
elected officials writers thinkers for a
couple days every year and for two years
from 2020 and 2021 the theme of the
conference was sortition and spaces of
power um
and I was on my way up I I attend I
signed up to attend the conference as
someone who uh was on their way to
become a social studies uh uh teacher I
was I was thinking of I just quit my job
at a community Outreach Center in Sunset
Park Brooklyn where I live worked at a
community health center for 3
years and was ready to go back into
teaching thought that was the best way
for me to to be working with young
people on Civics and getting young
people engaged in democracy that's
really what drives me
um this conference blew my mind because
I had no idea about the history of
random selection
sortition um in it you know made me feel
quite ignorant but it's also a failure
of our public school system I think um
and it totally energized me I was
feeling quite down about the
possibilities for
comprehensive um approaches and
solutions to what we are facing as a
society I felt like our society was
collapsing around me I feel like we were
not coming up with the sort of
collaborative problem solving mechanisms
that we desperately needed and when I
started learning about these assemblies
at the uh conference and and uh um I was
I was re-energized and for the past two
and a half years
essentially basically all of my time has
been dedicated to organizing a space at
the arent center called the Democracy
Innovation Hub that tries to energize
others around these same issues the same
the same model although I would say
we're not obsessed with one model we
don't think citizens assemblies are
going to save the world or that there's
one type of assembly that should be
implemented
everywhere um I think what inspired me
and re-energized me was the idea of
bringing everyday people not just to get
to uh come into a room and and and talk
but to have a the question that that
really has inspired me is if you were to
design an ideal learning space that
empowered people to take action over
their own lives and the lives of their
communities what would it look like I
think if you try to answer that you you
get something towards a citizen's
assembly of of a of a of some sort
um this idea of bringing people together
and intentionally mixing in the society
intentionally mixing the society getting
people to see other parts of the society
that they are not inter interacting with
every day um from all kinds you know
Crossing barriers in neighborhoods um is
something that inspired me and so what
have we been doing at the at the center
we've run three major convenings um the
first one was was 2022 uh we had over 50
um participants up in the Hudson Valley
at Bard and the the intent similar to an
assembly is that we try to really bring
together people that are maybe not
talking to each other but are are
somewhat could be primed or could be
interested in this model and we say
let's work together to scale some of
these and co-design them from a
place-based perspective that is let's
not just copy what X Y and Z country or
or place is doing let's ask what would
it mean to rebuild trust in our Loc it
from the ground up but also from the
inside out and the outside in so we've
done that we've been doing that in the
Hudson Valley and so there's there's
working groups of uh both elected
officials and everyday people who have
come together to start exploring these
ideas in um in and around Bard and then
we've also done that in New York City
where I live you heard from forest
earlier
um essentially we've run these these
these uh two convenings and one uh
teacher training workshop and the last
convening uh really brought together the
teachers with the elected officials and
Community leaders so we had over 140
people in New York City um just a few
weeks ago um and it was a really
inspiring Dynamic group of people
exploring models from all over the world
but then importantly it wasn't just it's
like how do we model this like if you
even think about the way this room is
structured the way we were doing public
meetings the way we do conferences if we
start thinking with a with a design
perspective we could redesign the way
we're doing a lot of these convenings to
Workshop these ideas now again this is
not coming from a research perspective
this is like I'm I'm way on the applied
side right but the idea is to bring to
to to have it be a mix of academics
practitioners um uh Advocates students
young people they should be in the room
co-designing these processes thinking
through how they might work how they're
affected by them
um and so that last convening we've just
done really a of a lot of of a lot of
the work we're doing training teachers
doing workshops with City agencies
trying to figure out um how a process
might fit into a city agency how a city
agency could pilot a process um and so
we workshopped two uh live initiatives
in New York City in this last convening
one was um energized New York that you
heard about earlier today and another
one was a was a possible assembly on
some topic with the mayor's office of of
Engagement in New York
City um so that's kind of our model is
like you build a you build a space and
then you ask people you invite people in
to to co-design uh the the the assembly
or the or the series of assemblies with
you the last thing I would just say is
that we're at the Hana rent Center and
there is a a deep theoretical connection
to her work and her you know that that
conference that inspired me this this
idea of of it being a deeply human thing
to need to be seen in public to need to
appear in public with other people and
to take action with other people as
being deeply human is why we're is one
of the reasons uh we're at the rent
Center and um yeah I'm happy to be here
I hope I didn't go over my time you're
good you're great finally Chris take
this
out great um thank you it is wonderful
to be here and I'm really grateful to be
um learning from folks that are so
studied and so uh such deep experts on
this issue on these various um these
various approaches to democracy and
thank you Ally for inviting me and also
for hosting this um I have found it to
be so interesting and as the neoy in the
room I think the resident neoy um I just
I'm thrilled to kind of uh hear about
all the various Innovative approaches
that um that governments that
organizations and that um certainly
researchers are taking um to innovate
democracy um so I come uh as Ali
mentioned from meta and am thrilled to
be here because um at meta we are taking
um the first steps that we believe are
important to democratize inputs into our
Innovation and so my team is the
governance team we sit at the
intersection of technology and Society
our mission is to really Elevate user
voice into our Innovation um and so our
Flagship initiative which we launched
three years ago is um as Ally mentioned
is called the oversight board it's been
termed the Supreme Court for Facebook
but essentially it is a recourse or
redressal mechanism um that everyday
users can um appeal to it's an
independent institution that we that we
established um but we have uh in
enshrined through a series of bylaws and
governing documents that it has
independent decision-making and binding
authority over meta um when it comes to
individuals content so if you use one of
meta's platforms and you disagree with
the decision that we've taken on your
content for the first time in human
history you can appeal to an external
body that has binding authority over the
company and so we think that that's a
really important first step in governing
um in governing the company and
divesting power away from a small set of
individuals at at one company to have
such an impact on things like freedom of
expression but we also recognize that
fundamentally that is a redressal
mechanism or recourse mechanism and so
um we have been experimenting over the
past two years in De in deliberative
discourse and deliberative democracy to
democratize inputs into our Innovation
at the onset so we've been really really
thrilled to start taking steps in this
direction and to um iterate throughout
um throughout each pilot that we've that
we have um we've pursued um about two
years ago we um ran our first pilot that
was focused on what we should do on
climate misinformation on our platform
um the second pilot that we held was
about a year ago and it was on specific
policies related to the metaverse and
then most recently we were thrilled to
host a um a community Forum that's our
term for it um on generative Ai and the
principles that should underpin how we
innovate our generative AI products and
so I can share just a little bit about
the approach each one has been slightly
different um but we partner um as a as a
company we partner with stamford's
deliberative democracy lab um to do a
deliberative poll so that's actually the
the format of the mechanism um and then
we also partner with the behavioral
insights team a behavioral economics
organization um and social science um
firm um to help us uh design and to also
vet our materials and our approach Ro
and our design to ensure it's um as as
free as possible from bias and so um the
way that the the process works and um
we've been really pleased to date but
we're also really open to innovating
further um is that um we seek out a
representative sample of the public we
use a a polling firm so people don't
need to actually be users on our
platforms they don't need to have any
any um specific expertise we go out and
recruit um everyday people that want to
participate um we then provide them an
education uh education packet with uh
background on the topic that we are
seeking their input on um that packet
has background um background context
that's written um at a at an accessible
level we work with the behavioral
insights team to do that to make it
tangible and accessible um and then um
we provide that packet as a pre-read to
participants participants then um join
the The Forum remotely and virtually
through stamford's deliber ative
platform that is AI facilitated and
guides them through without human
moderation um guides the participants
through a series of questions and
proposals so we um we may have an
overarching topic that we want their
feedback on um but we provide in the
education material a series of different
ideas that um for how we might approach
a particular problem and um the
associated pros and cons to unpack the
tensions that are um inherent with
within that particular topic so for
example on the the most recent um Forum
on generative AI we wanted to hear
people's perspectives on how um how
chatbots should foster connection with
humans it's a major topic um because
chatbots have such great promise in
generative AI such great promise to
alleviate um symptoms of loneliness
there's there's a growing a small but
growing body of evidence about its
utility in cognitive behavioral therapy
um but at the same time there's also
real risks in um for people engaging
with chatbots there was one famous case
in Europe in which um one individual
committed suicide after engaging a
chatbot and it encouraged him to commit
suicide and so these are these are um
technologies that are transformative but
also have um real risk for offline harm
and so we wanted to ask participants
about what they thought on how chapot
should establish connections with humans
and as a part of that we would unpack
the pros and the cons of a series of of
proposals
um the the participants enter this
platform they engage with one another
they debate and share their perspectives
we then um provide access to a panel of
experts that have technical expertise
human rights expertise research
expertise and the participants are able
to ask questions of these part um of
these experts and then there's a session
in which um participants then leave the
expert panel can debrief with one
another and share what they learned um
and the way that we actually solicit
their direct input is through a
deliberate this is a deliberative poll
and so they take a poll before and after
the Forum um so that we can understand
how their views may have changed um and
so we think that this has been kind of a
really great experiment in deliberative
discourse our first kind of learnings
from the from the pilots um we're still
pending the results from from this
particular Forum um but that we've been
really thrilled that people first of all
um as I think evidenced by all the all
the research and everything that's been
shared here people are willing and they
are able to engage deeply with one
another on very complex issues and so it
gives us great hope that people can um
can discuss some of the most pressing
issues of our time and actually develop
and develop really rich meaningful
results through deliberation um the the
other learning is that um people
appreciate having a voice and um that's
something that we have found with the
oversight board in terms of empowering
people to appeal to a body that can
overrule meta um but we also recogn and
I think um the data to date in our
forums suggests that people actually
there's a there's a um a positive um
change in which they they have cited
that they have been really um
appreciating the experience um but we
also know that these the legitimacy of
such systems only matter and we've heard
this throughout the day-to-day um only
matter when there's actually tangible
outcomes that come from these forums and
so whereas our oversight board has
binding authority over meta this model
is advisory in nature and so what we are
doing moving forward is developing a
much more robust way that we can share
how the the results of the Forum and how
the feedback that we receive from the
participants actually will inform our
Innovation moving forward um and then
lastly I would just say that um we
believe um through this through this
particular model that technology offers
a great opportunity to scale discourse
um and I know a lot of the um
deliberative assemblies in history have
been in person um given meta's scale SC
of having over 3 billion users on our
platforms um and given the global nature
of the company we really are looking to
technology to be something that can be
an enabler um at the same time that
creates its own set of risks Ally was
one of our observers at The Forum a
couple weeks ago and we've had great
conversations and she's offered great
feedback about the unevenness um that
comes inherent with technology so
there's this great promise of scale but
also a potential risk of of uneven
uneven discourse and so we're just
really looking forward to continuing to
innovate further I think I really
appreciated the spirit of kind of
throughout the day people talking about
different models and what might work
here might not work in another context
and what may have worked in in the past
may not necessarily work in the future
and so we're very open-minded to
continuing to innovate but I think our
mission really moving forward is to
continue to to solicit um input and to
democratize inputs into the company
thanks excellent thank you Chris as you
can see we constructed the panel with a
wide range of viewpoints and so now
we're going to um discuss a lot of
pressing issues about lotteries that tap
into each of the panelists individual
expertise but we're going to start with
the big one kind of the elephant in the
room which is assume that democracy is
dying and elections are broken should we
just get rid of Elections should we make
a radical change and stop electing our
politicians so our congressmen or our
parliamentarians if you're in Europe uh
and switch to a sortition based in
institution is that possible should we
do it uh Demitri or fed if one of you
want to take this one okay I'll start um
I I have a sense that you know defenses
of mini Publix often have two two
components um a kind of a very
pessimistic almost almost Mor element
and highly optimistic you know sometimes
even joyous one the the pessimistic has
to do with the existing electoral
institutions and the uh and the
optimistic one has to do with you know
Wonderful replacements that are being
suggested including of course autocratic
institutions and I'm not sure that this
is an Apples to Apples comparison um I
think there's a kind of a tendency that
goes with this of course to see the
status quo to treat the status quo
institutions as the proper uh Benchmark
version of representative democracy this
is this is it folks right that like that
um but I'm not and and if it is then
maybe we should get rid of Elections
right maybe maybe that's right but that
seems a little too hasty um and I don't
I don't think that the status quo
version of representative democracy is
the is the proper Benchmark version um
and and so I I do think it's a
comparison of an apple to an orange uh a
kind of inferior um institutional form
of electoral regime to potentially
Superior or arguably Superior uh within
the set of autocratic regimes on
institutional form of another you know
if we're talking about autocracies or if
we're talking about modified direct
democracies some kind of modified direct
democracy version uh which to say I
don't think that's a fair comparison um
there are many ways it seems to me in
which we might go about reforming
electoral systems from within without
giving up on the idea of electoral
representation or of political
accountability on which the idea of
electoral representation rests um One
important principle of institutional
design that I think um kind of speaks to
many concerns that um lrac critics of
Elections have raised is that is a very
intuitive idea that we should seek to
minimize the influence of the political
actors over the rules of their own
political
contests uh the basic intuition there is
that it's precisely that kind of
influence that gives rise to corrupted
electoral system and of course very few
electoral regimes today come anywhere
close to implementing this principle so
it seems to me that there are and this
is just one example but it seems to me
that there are many ways in which we
might look to institutionalize something
like this including by the way VIA
something like uh um you know randomly
selected electoral Commission that
Christian was speaking about earlier
today um so there's a lot of room for
Innovation and improvement from within
the electoral system so I I I think it's
too
hasty um yeah I I agree with that and
I'm just going to add uh one thing I I
don't I don't think I guess I'm I'm
challenging the premise on on a
different uh uh aspect I don't think
that democracy is D if democracy is
dying I don't think that democracy is
dying because of Elections or uniquely
because of Elections um and what I see
in the research that I conduct on uh uh
premodern democracies or Collective
governance um is that elections are in
fact an element in the soup of
collective governance um and so what
seems to me urgent however is to
question the role of Elections as a
unique sort of a form of for eliciting
the uh um popular preferences um and to
identify the proper space for electoral
politics Visa V autocratic policy or
other types of of policy um the problem
however seems to me and I think that the
the the discussion that we had today
sort of cemented some of the uh ideas
that I arguably came into this this
conference with which is that we really
lack the social science uh to address
this question to properly understand uh
the relative value and the scope of
different types of uh selection
mechanisms um and I what what what
worries me is that um again as a social
scientist I think that we do really need
to put some of our uh brains onto this
question of trying to understand the
relative scope and uh value of different
mechanisms uh but listening to uh you
know practitioners I wonder if uh you
know how the social science actually
needs to be integrated and integrate
with um experiments uh particular
experiments where we see like sort of an
attempt to just come into the room
saying forget what we know about the
past let alone what happened five
minutes ago um but uh then to think
about like how to co-design these spaces
I'm I'm really of two minds about what
the relative value of each approach
might be and I think that ultimately we
might need
both and you know both panelists bring
up a good point and that there are many
ways to use lotteries and actually our
ability as social scientists to collect
empirical data on the highest levels is
really hard right because these are
governing institutions with real life
politicians parties that are established
but we see a new wave a deliberative
wave of Institutions being implemented
all over so citizens assemblies or
redistricting or oversight boards and so
maybe this is the future and I was
wondering Phil could you maybe uh argue
for including more deliberative
institutions or the types of activities
that your organization does uh where
should we start if not at the very top
where should we start at maybe local
levels and getting local governments
involved to incorporate
lotteries yeah absolutely
um the way I've been thinking about this
and the way I think a lot of people I I
mean I say a lot like the handful of
folks who are also in educational
institutions um which are naturally
anchor institutions in communities right
they order food from a a local catering
uh company they serve students right
especially if they're public school is
how does how do you think about re you
know reinvigorating local democracy from
a place-based
perspective um what I been really
inspired by is this idea that fed um
kind of hinted at which is
experimenting and collaborating with
both um academics but then you know
local Teachers Community leaders on some
hard issue that's actually happening in
the community so for instance in
Lancaster Pennsylvania um at Franklin
and Marshall um they've been running
deliberative forums there um you know at
the University space for the past year I
only found out about this a couple weeks
ago but I was immediately inspired to
say yeah that's a great model that we
can take back to Bard we have not been
running deliberative forums a big part
of what the way I see these and the way
we see them at the rent Center is as as
schools as like gyms for democracy right
again I said if you're going to design a
space that gives people the the
Practical tools for practicing democracy
it would look something like a Citizens
assembly
so I mean sitting in a classroom and
learning about Civics in a passive way
it's just it I don't know if it was ever
a good idea you know I don't know if it
was that was ever design I don't know if
it was good for the 20th century I I
doubt it I think the things that
inspired me to be a citizen were going
out and working on campaigns that
mattered to me when I was 17 that's why
I'm still involved in Pol in you know
policy or democracy in some way and so
if you give young people especially but
also just community members a different
way to engage and you Empower them and
you also mix them with other folks that
they wouldn't normally encounter
um through some delivera of experience
but in a very structured way again I
think like we're often blind to the
amazing sort of capacity of our human
capacity to facilitate we we don't
engage in that we don't build that
muscle in our society like we don't
build that collaborative muscle and I
think if we started to think about what
would it mean to to give young people
the muscles and the the capacity to
facilitate dialogue in their Community
like that's a win no matter what we can
start doing that I don't I I mean maybe
there's a I'd love to hear a cter
argument against this but like problem
solving uh active listening um
psychosocial skills that enable people
to collaborate on better problems like I
I'm sure meta would love to hire more
people that are good at that right so I
I think if we start doing that as
educational institutions on real
existing projects locally um partnering
with elected officials who want to
facilitate some deliberative processes
not just deliberations but also leading
to action that's the way we've been
thinking about it from the Democracy
Innovation Hub is like bring all those
folks that we can together being
anchored in one place so not trying to
say like this is some solution but
bringing people in to think through this
and be inspired by the international
examples like that's the one thing we've
we've really seen that when you bring
people in and give them case studies of
like look Bogota and Colombia is doing
this like why don't we try it right like
people need that right now people are
especially young people are are deeply
cynical about the systems we're in so we
need to to come up with ways to to um
give them Pathways to action that are
not just look at how look at how bad
everything is you
know okay so we need to be more
optimistic and give uh the Youth of
today more opportunities to get involved
in politics that may be non-traditional
so it's not just go vote but it's uh you
know develop policy positions with
people you might never have encountered
before can I say one more thing to that
okay so that's one thing like I've
worked on a lot of campaigns and I've
been I've been burnt out by campaigns
when you work in this political system
you try to achieve a certain goal and
your whole outlook is I'm going to try
to get as many votes or as many XYZ and
then it's it's all or nothing that it's
good sometimes it is all or nothing and
it's good to have that Spirit but like
especially young people are craving that
sort of uh Christian in your
presentation you mentioned that like the
call to action the public service we are
just failing to say to have ambition
about what it would look like if we
called the public to action in a
non-dogmatic ideological way in a
problem solving way I think so I think
um yeah I think that aspect of like
getting young people involved in in
re-energizing democracy that isn't just
about a specific campaign or a specific
individual like getting someone elected
that's necessary I'm absolutely against
replace like getting rid of Elections
like or are having that framework right
now but I think that model does lead to
burnout and disappointment because you
it's if you think you're you're going to
win everything by getting one person in
office like you're you're delusional but
young people want to be a part of those
kind of campaigns
no I think that's absolutely right I'm
going to use that as a segue to talk
about how uh not just young people but
Society is changing and that we're going
digital we got our information from
different sources we just you know lived
through a pandemic where zoom and other
kind of forms of uh digital
communication became our Lifeline for a
while and what's interesting if we think
about scale and how to involve more
people in deliberative activities um I
think actually meta is incredibly
fascinating um example of this now I got
to be an observer um and it was it was a
remarkably well-run platform the the
groups were engaging um you know the
groups kind of acted if you teach right
how do you get students to discuss in a
deliberate Forum you know how do you get
someone from Florida someone who's
zooming in from New York someone who's
from a you know who uh worked in AI
versus who's worried about losing their
job in AI it was a fascinating
experience and maybe the future right so
if uh meta is experimenting doing this
at scale and bringing deliberative
institutions um into a different to
Industry not democracy right to Industry
um I think that's incredibly promising
um so I want to hear a little bit more
Chris about um you do you think that
this is something meta will continue
with um obviously you've had positive
experience but does the platform see it
as a positive experience are you going
to keep expanding so millions of users
will give input about issues of today
what do you think the future of this is
yeah I think it's I mean great question
um uh so it is interesting because
actually in one of our Pilots to do to
establish proof of concept of scale the
metaverse community form which I
mentioned which a pilot um it was a year
ago actually was larger than this more
recent one on on generative AI it was
6,000 people across 30 countries in 23
languages what we
understood may have been although I I
can't necessarily prove the negative but
may have been the largest deliberate
exercise at once in human history um and
so certainly scale the technology allows
for a scale that is um I think probably
Rises to the needs of this of of this
moment right where in trusted
institutions are collapsing kind of
globally right and so and there's
there's less and less confidence in
institutions and so that may require and
particularly in uh particularly emerging
Technologies with um that No No
Boundaries may require Global solution
or a global input so I think the
technology you know we think that it
should be a part of the solution because
these Technologies are um transformative
in in what they can bring to society but
they're also as we've seen in recent
history transformative in some in some
of the risks and so um we have been
really kind of thrilled with the with
the way that this enables scale again it
can also create unevenness but there's
also other experiments happening as well
um so um I have to acknowledge kind of
other industry efforts to do um to to
democratize inputs anthropic recently um
published a Blog where they used the um
the software polus to do something
called um Collective constitutional AI
so anthropic kind of released the their
constitution maybe I don't actually
maybe a year ago called constitutional
AI that underpinned kind of the rules
and the and the Paradigm in which their
their chatbot Cloud um will operate um
based off of and more recently they used
polus which is a kind of
realtime uh AI facilitated um
crowdsourcing tool to gather more
perspectives from people and then inform
kind of a different constitutional AI so
and um the digital um the the minister
of digital Affairs in Taiwan Audrey Tang
is doing something similar using um not
just uh related to AI but using polish
software to crowdsource her um her
populace and the the uh Taiwanese
population to inform kind of where
there's alignment on certain policy
issues or where there's polarization and
so um you know yes I think meta we're
really really excited about the
community fors we're really excited
about this platform that can enable
discourse at scale um we obviously saw
during the pandemic because Zoom there
was there was um fat Zoom fatigue
famously um but even if it's not that
particular platform or that particular
model Tech there's other organizations
experimenting with technology I think it
it has to be the future
um but in the spirit of innovation and
everything I've heard here I think that
um it would behoove anyone that's in
this space to really iterate further and
I was really struck by Fred R's comments
um earlier in her talk about you know
maybe the model isn't necessarily the
same when you in every region maybe you
need to meet regions where they are
based on their cultural context and so
maybe you have a much more flexible
model um all enabled by technology maybe
but maybe you change the model depending
on where you are depending about the uh
those individual
needs actually I was about to wrap up uh
so anyways I would just say I think uh
technology super exciting also you know
relatively untested and we should
continue to innovate uh fed do you have
a followup on kind of uh digital
Collective governance or anything about
the new online sphere we find ourselves
in um yeah and maybe this will sound
peculiar said by me but I think that the
idea that we would uh sort of like a
self defea inly uh uh eliminate the
affordances that technology uh gives us
for uh participation for collaboration
uh would be would be absurd and and
detrimental I think uh and so in a world
in which we necessarily uh sort of
engage with technology to achieve these
types of uh radically perhaps
decentralized and at scale forms of
collaboration and participation um I
think that as Chris has already
suggested uh we need to be very much
aware of the pit Falls um and I think
that there is one particular pitfalls
that I am concerned about when it comes
to technology mediated particularly
generative AI mediated uh collaboration
and participation which is uh
essentially like what both Philip and um
and Forest earlier discussed at at the
heart of uh the sort of Engagement and
participation that they see which is the
texure of Civic norms and of just like
collaborative Norms that is built I
think uh more likely in uh spaces where
people come together physically and
engage now this might be empirically
incorrect I'm I stand to be uh sort of
like a a a proven uh false uh but I
think that it is something truly to
consider the degree to Which online
virtual engagements make us even more
exposed to the possibility of missing
out on this fundamental uh sort of
architecture of social norms that is
essentially what brings us together and
what makes democracy work um and so
that's that I think uh something that um
any use of technology in these spaces
would have to
consider and the last question anyone
can take this before we open it up to
the audience so technological advances
means it's easier to talk to folks who
are not physically present so maybe our
communication ability has increased but
we are also in a world uh many places
there's a lot of polarization in
particular effective polarization right
so we seem like we're more divided even
though it's easier to talk and when we
think about who um participates in
deliberative mini public who responds to
the invitation to go debate with fellow
citizens for a weekend giving up time
and effort should we be worried that U
maybe not in all places but in some
countries um the US in particular it's
you know it's more common in Europe all
of these institutions than it is in the
US um is this something we should be
concerned about do people not want to
talk to each other anymore and so either
the practitioners who have gotten people
together or academics who have studied
and thought about polarization in
institutions um anyone can take this but
should we be worried that polarization
will slow down the benefits of
deliberative
democracy go
ahead um I think I think one of the
dangers of polarization is is this kind
of siloed um learning through
reinforcement by passively observing
others rather than engaging
deliberatively with them and passively
observing others who essentially like us
I think it's the kind of thing that you
know that leads uh it's it's less about
immediate AFF effect and more about
arriving at posterior beliefs and
positions that are that are potentially
mistaken that are influenced by signals
from others that are not independent
signals that are sort of from the set of
people who are very much like us it's
the kind of thing that leads to people
arriving at people coming to view
themselves as having very strong
posteriors such that the there's no
point in engaging in in deliberation um
so it's a substitution of kind of
passively reinforced beliefs for a for
actively searching debate or
conversation um it's a process that
generates relatively stable contentious
posteriors without turning um into kind
of a contentious but open-ended and
possibly corrective discourse I'm I'm
worried about that as an effective
polarization so it's not so much an off
effect but this kind of effect on how we
perceive the nature of the disagreement
and our own beliefs relative to the
disagreement Phil have you seen this in
your
practitioning I would say being at bar
to Progressive liberal arts college uh
in the Hudson
Valley I've been of two minds one is we
need to put out the call as quickly and
as f as as as strongly as possible that
there are other modes of uh engaging in
democracy citizens assemblies are it's
it's a sort of call to action right the
issue is that the people who are primed
for that even at this point primed for
even the word democracy
are somewhere to the left of where the
right is right now
so you're you're it's an uphill battle
to sort of reach across the aisle and
sometimes it feels like a naive attempt
or like let's say this I try to avoid
the sort of the the partisan
polarization because I think if you get
in like oh we're going to try to get the
Reds and the Blues in the in the room
together it kind of misses the point
where it's like most people probably
don't associate with like as a red or a
blue or republican Democrat um so if you
try to take the place-based perspective
and say like anyone out there who wants
to try to create a a a better sort of
more collaborative form of democracy
like even thinking through the language
on how we talk about citizens assemblies
is like one of the
things you know at first it was the sort
we were it was the sortition project at
at Bard and it was just like no one
knows what that is sounds super academic
people are going to write it off as like
some idea like okay now it's the
Democracy Innovation Hub after our last
conference we were like should we call
it the the center for citizen power you
know like because there's a question of
of how to relate to in this rapidly
polarized like World in which language
is CH changed so quickly um I think we
just have to make the effort and not
worry too much about um like I think if
the intention is there to meet people
where they're at and to be open about
disagreement um about tough issues I
think that's the most important thing
but I would say like the the the the
people that tend to come to us or email
me have like participated in
participatory budgeting right like
they're they're so there's there's got
to be an intention from from these
efforts as we're organizing them both as
Citizens or as educational institutions
to say we're going to do as best as we
can to to you know reach across
different aisles or reach across
different sections of the population um
without you know reproducing the sort of
stereotype of that
idea that that already exists I don't
know if that that helps answer the
question at all no and I mean
Recruitment and getting the word out
that there are these positive
experiences from deliberative miniu or
particip participatory budgeting that is
also the more the work of the people in
the room expands the more people will
know and that's also one of the goals of
this conference um so we are actually
going to open it up to the audience so
audience members if you could raise your
hand very high and uh Pam will come and
give you a
microphone and please introduce yourself
when you so hi everyone I'm I'm elen
lore I'm a professor of political
science at at Yale University I think
some of you um at least maybe will know
me as one of the optimists about mini
public and pessimists about electoral
democracy and thank you so much for this
conference and this panel it's it's it's
truly extraordinary I think and uh very
symbolically also I think that it's one
of the first conferences on lotteries
that I um I think has taken place here I
don't think I organized one I should
have but anyway I'm glad
to so I have question for each of you if
uh if I'm allowed uh so fed first I I
was wondering if you had thoughts on how
the Greeks uh the ancient Greeks solves
the objections raised by dimitry so how
come they for let's say 200 years um did
without elections and yet were
relatively stable and didn't get
captured at least you know uh to you
know to in a way that damages our system
too much by by I know Local Economic
Elites like how what so Dimitri it's
it's a question to you as well does the
Greek case answer some of your questions
or not or is it a completely different
case because we're not talking about a
transition from an electoral system to
you know mini public based system but
it's a completely different system that
never had elections for political
functions I have a question for uh Chris
very very nice to meet you I am excited
to hear more about uh what you're doing
at meta uh so given uh the objections
from Dimitri again about you know what
happens when you don't give people real
power in in particular and the risk of
you know losing their interest or
motivation and your own claim that
you're looking to make the opinions of
the participants a bit more
binding um should you move towards more
of a Citizens assembly model actually
where it's not just about polling people
at the end but getting them to
deliberate towards a goal towards a
recommendation towards a binding
resolution and then they would function
more like your over oversight board
potentially just a thought um and also I
can I have to ask like what have you
learned at meta from the open AI uh
governance you know or board failure of
the last week um I would love to to hear
what you have to say because they were
structured as a a nonprofit and that
that board totally failed you're
structured as a for-profit and you're
seemingly successfully equipping
yourselves
with um constraints of some sort I don't
know how you know constraint they truly
are but they they look like they could
be uh dimitry
now um I I would love to be less of a
pessimist about electoral systems and
and I so I I'm willing to believe that
under some different circumstances
somewhere they could be great
but I'd like to hear what do you think
is is is a standard of success and and
how do you address the the the criticism
one could make based on the sort of a
plutocratic Tendencies of of those
systems there's a an article in the
British Journal of political science
that came out in June that shows that
across like 30 countries 40 years 2,000
issues there's a systematic over
representation or over congruence uh
greater congruence with the preferences
of of um of of rich people in these
countries uh you know policies match
their preferences more than they match
the preferences of poor people for
example or majorities even so so that
seems to be a systematic problem and
maybe there's a trade of there that I'm
not seeing that we're g we're gaining
more competence we're gaining something
stability or better protection of
minority you know in exchange for that
plutocratic bias but I I would love to
hear uh what it is did I um oh yeah and
um
Philip I have a question for you too I I
I hear about your work and and how
seemingly um you know officials at the
city level maybe the state level are
getting somewhat interested in miniu and
lotteries but somehow at the federal
level I I find it very dispiriting how
you know the Democracy Summits organized
by Biden systematically failed to
mention deliberative democracy miniu
lotteries it's not a all on their agenda
why is that and what can be done thank
you sorry it was very long but excellent
questions um we'll just go fed if you
want to start we'll go down the
table um hien thank you for the question
um so the Greeks the the athans did have
elections they Ed elections to um select
a a few magistrates we don't have
evidence of uh elections in the large
bodies that we associate with the
democracies the courts the assembly uh
and the council uh but this is I guess
it is certainly a situation in which
there isn't a full-fledged electoral
democratic system that then needs to be
replaced with a lot of rical other types
of Institutions but the Greeks were
certainly not unaware of Elections as a
as a mechanism uh I think that as far as
we can tell uh by looking at people that
have studied these questions uh
extensively uh democracy without
elections in this the vast majority of
sort of a qual is the decision-making
process uh uh in a situation that didn't
lead to either El lead capture but also
and I think that this is the problem
that uh the the situation in Athens
really uh generated which is
um the avoidance of elite capture is one
aspect of the story the other aspect of
the story is the avoidance of popular
ignorance so how do a bunch of uh people
on the sitting on a hill uh decide on
matters of War and Peace and finance uh
without really being experts this is
Plato's problem um and I think that some
of the authors that have looked at this
question including of course uh Josh oer
have really looked at the political
discourse at the texture of Civic norms
and how very simple mechanisms for
selection for decision- making uh
created a situation in which people
shared uh information and learned uh
from coming together in these Public
public body so again I think that my
work today is sort of like a pushing
against the idea that we should continue
to obsess with ancient aens but adance
remains a fundamental uh sort of like a
place to learn about uh ancient
democracies and premodern
democracies okay
Dimitri um so I am going to defer to F
Rico and all questions having to do with
ancient
a um I I do want to um respond to elen's
question about how to think about the
relative advantages at least in
principle relative advantages of
representative democracy I think um one
uh one dimension where there is
something to be said in particular about
uh representation has to do with
complexity of governance um I think um
um uh direct Democratic forms um lcrac
forms are particularly attractive when
um issued Dimensions can be um can be
isolated and dealt with in in an
isolated way without generating um
massive externalities with respect to
other dimensions I think when you talk
about policymaking that has these kinds
oftion pleas so I think when you talk
about policym with respect to issues
that have these kinds of cross-issue
externalities I think that's where there
is some value there's considerable value
I would say right for something like
representative uh electoral process with
policy makers who are um who are given
um uh a jurisdiction right that that
encompasses multiple issues and that's
and and I think that's where you know
and and I think our world is sort of
increasingly like that right or has been
increasingly like that for uh you know
for at least for the last uh two plus
Millennia since um you know since since
ancient ethens um so I think so that's
that's the way I would direct the
argument okay Phil
okay um so I think
uh we need to run workshops in DC with
Federal uh government officials and we
just basically we need to find more
folks who are willing to organize knock
doors talk call elected officials um I
think it's already happening and I don't
even think I know that there's other
people out there do starting to do this
work that haven't connected because we
haven't had enough of these convenings
so um I just came back from DC uh
yesterday uh um at the National
Conference of on citizenship the future
of citizenship and there was a workshop
with Maran isassi and um and Jillian
Youngblood and John gastl um on citizens
assemblies at the National Conference of
citizenship there's now a democracy
Innovation um Center within the um
National civic league and I I think
basically
um we need to
organize just I'm like
my yes I I think we basically need to
organize convenings and I think it would
be great if Bard and Yale and other
colleges thought of this from a
collaborative mindset instead like
that's the other thing like all of these
institutions are set up to have a a
competitive mindset if we got together
and said how do we scale more
collaborative uh um uh attempts at this
together rather than separately I think
we could have a bigger impact obviously
it cannot just be like Elite
institutions it's got to be from a a
multi-stakeholder um perspective but
these convenings where in where anchor
institutions have the space and the
convening space I think um I I mean one
thing over the next couple months and
especially this year 2024 if we can
Channel some convenings not to run
citizen assemblies but to do things that
are workshopping ideas and calling out
to people because this year A lot of
people are going to be like
I don't like either of these candidates
I'm depressed about the way this is
going I wish there was some way for me
to get
involved so that my my pitch is let's
convene a lot of those actors and then
bring in the elected officials and do
this
multi-stakeholder um these convenings
and workshop ideas from from multiple
angles and I think we'll will be
successful I think I think uh
politicians would are there are going to
be politicians who start to embrace this
as forms of of the next form of
democracy from uh younger Generations
especially and also for The Graduate
students in the room this sounds like a
great idea for a future dissertation or
future research okay Chris finally
wonderful thank you for the questions um
really nice to meet you I am as I've
mentioned a neoy in this space but very
have followed your work um very much an
admirer um so on the um on the citizens
assembly or the construct that we're
using deliberative polling versus
citizens assembly I think uh open to
Innovation right I think there's a
couple different factors that um that
are unique to a corporate setting that
we just need to be mindful of when
creating these types of mechanisms as
far as I know there's not a lot of
companies that have done this and so I
think we're trying to find our way
through it in a way that is as
productive as possible that gives that
honors the the the spirit of these
mechanisms while also recognizing the
like unique constraints of operating in
a for-profit company and so um the the
deliberative polling method seems to be
efficient scalable kind of also
recognizes that the nature of technology
is so fast evolving and so the questions
that we might be asking may not
necessarily be the same things as um a
government may be asking citizens to
weigh in on a Citizens assembly the
generative AI Community forum for
example is much more directional since
generative AI is different than was six
months ago it's going to be different in
six six months in the future and so we
are looking for directional feedback
rather than some sort of specific policy
outcome um but I think you know there's
we have not put to bed any of any other
type of model and I think we're very
open to it so would love to continue the
conversation um but this we think is
kind of the first step towards um
democratizing inputs in a way that that
elevates user voice um but is um and
does so at the onset of our Innovation
rather than something that's a redressal
or um uh recourse
mechanism um on the open AI thing you
know corporate structure I'm not really
an expert in it I understand the
nonprofit versus for-profit structure I
think for me it just actually reaffirms
the need to infuse um Democratic inputs
Infuse governance into Innovation
because if you're relying on a corporate
structure to do that um like a nonprofit
board um that clearly is not um uh it's
it's it's not um imper to to potential
corrup I don't want to say corruption
but potential challenges right and so um
I I think if anything it just shows that
we need to actually imbue our Innovation
with governance and um that's why I'm
excited to work on
it okay other questions from the
audience
Kevin thanks yes this is fascinating and
interesting to have all these different
perspectives um so so my question might
it's coming from a little bit from this
question about about sort of uh the the
top down why is there no interest in
this at the federal level um so one of
the so the sort of question I would pose
is like um absent a revolution um how
would you get from here to there right
how would you get from here to lcy so
think about this in terms of um absent a
revolution this is going to require
elected officials to transfer Authority
right they're going to have to adopt
these institutions for some reason so
that seems to me suggest like uh one set
of questions um uh that we might have
answers to that we want to have answers
to are what can deliberative manyu do
for elected leaders um and I don't just
mean things like we can improve our
democracy they're not really going to
care about that right um what can it do
for them in a more mercenary way now
that mercenaries can can be a bunch of
different things one thing would be like
it takes an issue like abortion off our
plates right in Ireland one of the
reason they want to do this they did not
want to deal with this question and
marriage equality that's going to blow
up our our party if we try to deal with
them that um another uh uh sort of
possibility and here is one that um I
know the beginning of the story but not
the end um so Mike neblo um for a while
was doing these um it was my
understanding he had members of Congress
especially freshmen were going to engage
in these um forums where they spoke with
their um randomly selected uh
constituents right yeah um and so
because one of the big challenges here
is is one way of thinking about this is
getting citizens to trust deliber many
publics but what about getting elected
officials who are the ones who are going
to have to transfer authority to these
institutions how do you get them uh uh
to trust them so I don't know how Mike's
thing has turned out I know he did some
some um Pilots but then he thought he
was doing a bigger one so I wonder what
you guys think about that I wonder if
you know how this has turned out maybe
other people in the room do um so yeah
so that that's sort of my question um uh
how can we do that uh and then um uh
because I feel like that might be a
solution to some of of these questions
about scaling up some of these questions
about about also the attractiveness
right if there's not a way to get from
here to there if there's not a way to
answer that question of what can this do
for for politicians absent Revolution
then you might be out out of
luck um you were looking at me mostly so
I'll try um the I think we asked them we
go so what we've been doing with for and
I've been doing is call up the mayor's
office we email this other agency we
email the department of transportation
we email the Senators we you know like
write Joe bid you know not we're not
going to write Joe Biden that's a bad
idea but basically what are you what
what is really hard and this is a model
we're not willing to just like spend all
of our time doing something for you as a
PR or like um engagement trick that
you're trying to run right like we're
citizens we think this model is is could
be the future of democracy what are you
willing to do power sharing on or to
think through or what is some issue that
could be really hard it that is an open
question that we have to go to the
agencies and we have to um like
basically the the the the things we've
learned from the folks in like Australia
or healthy democracy all you know um
we've been learning from folks who've
been doing this for for decades and they
go and they ask what is really difficult
like what's the most difficult thing you
face um and then they Workshop different
topics and then you have to figure out
tradeoffs and anything and then I don't
think from I think that starts a
conversation and then other
conversations open up like we've been
working with the mayor's office of
Engagement in New York and it turns out
that you know that's that's a unique
office because they uh they serve as a
coordinating role for all public
engagement from the city Side so they
have unique insights and they say well
you know so there's a whole conversation
that opens up and then there's a
conversation of how do we as Citizens
relate to this office right because it's
it's a it's trust building when when we
started doing it I honestly we've built
trust in a way in that having that
conversation from the inside and the
outside so I think like we basically
need to reach out and ask them how you
know what are what are the ways they
they would interact with this model and
then we learn oh some people want to use
it for bad reasons we don't want to work
with them some people have really good
ideas um maybe there's already an
existing thing that they're doing in
their agency that is a lot like this or
some citizen oversight board that we
could um help them implement it doesn't
have to be a Citizens assembly it's more
like let's let's meet people where
they're at and workshop these ideas I
that that's been our approach and also
sorry if I can just jump in one model to
look at is Belgium that has deliberative
committees that bring together elected
politicians and randomly selected
citizens to debate with each other so if
politicians are going to learn about the
efficacy of deliberate democracy that is
one way where if you treat all of those
politicians or at least we should be
looking to Belgium to see if politicians
those politicians that experienced
deliberative committees are more likely
to support the implementation of this
institution and in other levels um okay
another question oh I'm sorry yeah go
ahead I think the liberative many
publics give an opportunity to
politicians who do not want to Pander
right to uh an opportunity to um to
create an independent source of
information that might have some
standing among among their constituency
and and enable them to avoid pandering
so I think there is that kind of an it
doesn't obviously it's not true of every
politician it's true of politicians who
you know who would welcome an
opportunity to take a position that's
different from one that they're taking
and that could enable them to do that I
have just something slight add on to
that um aside from my role Mata I
there's a at University of Maryland I
believe his name Steven call um runs the
voice of the people which is a
deliberative poll outfit um they
specifically engage constituents and do
deliberative polls to uh to address
polarization to show U members of
Congress that actually when given
information and opportunity to engage
with one another people are not actually
is polarized and to hopefully um to to
um to encourage members of Congress to
to change positions on certain issues so
it's not the same but just another
another way that people are using
deliberation um to support the overall
kind of
system okay we have time for one more
question do we have another question
yeah right there Pam
Eliza um hey I'm Eliza Oak PhD candidate
in polyi here at Yale um so I'm curious
how you think about which decisions are
better suited for collective decision
making in the first place as opposed to
which decisions should be made by a
smaller group of experts and
representatives for example do you think
you know we should optimize around what
are the most controversial decisions
that the Public's divided on and hopes
of these discussions could kind of you
know encourage dialogue broader
consensus or of course course there's
other considerations maybe you know um
making sure the topic is sufficiently
approachable and not too complex but
curious especially for the practitioners
how you think about that in
practice please um thanks Eliza and I'm
a big fan of your work too I L the the
article that you wrote with Andy Hall
and you can teach me about web 3 and and
decentralized governance anytime um I
maybe I can just share a little bit of
how we're thinking about it I think
probably it's going to be a little bit
different from um some some folks that
focus more on public institutions um the
way that we have thought about it to
date is um because actually right now I
mean there's obviously things that are
highly contested um uh around social
media and Technology um but because a
lot of the technolog is emerging what
we've found is actually like you know
things on the metaverse or things even
on generative AI they're not super
polarized yet so for us we were looking
for um a lot of gray space where there's
not really necessarily a clear guiding
perspective either in public or at the
company um so where there's maybe not
polarized perspectives but maybe just
like a lack of consensus um where we
could explore and probe um again coming
from a a for-profit organization also
something that we're confident that we
would actually want to um hear public
inut input on right um there are some
decisions that um that the company is
going to say
um is is within the company's domain um
but that we would actually be able to to
um valuable um actually be able to um uh
solicit and put on and then the other
one is around um you know how do we
bring um participants along and is it
something that is not so technical um
that we could actually you know enable
through deliberation education and
expert engagement um people to to have a
rich discussion and give us valuable
feedback and something that they can
actually um uh participate in and so um
you know we found certainly through all
of our Pilots that we were impressed by
the richness of the discussions and the
deliberations even on things that are
are pretty technical but you can imagine
that coming from a technology company
there are things that are so and
actually um things like web 3 I mean I'm
not sure I'm not convinced that everyone
would be able to grasp every technical
detail about our technology and so um
finding something that is fit for
purpose um for for deliberation in terms
of the accessibility of the topic as
well okay Phil final response a brief
one if you can yeah I just point to uh
Forest uh if I don't think you saw
Forest presentation this morning but
it's recorded so he went through sort of
the way we're we thought about a
democratically legitimate way to arrive
at an issue in New York City around
energy and climate for instance which
you might have um some formal body team
of experts whether it's the and New York
version of the uh um
ipcc um deliver sort of the or or a team
of of University sort of professors who
have studied the the biggest climate
impacts or the biggest challenges facing
the energy system in New York right or
the energy transition um and then you
know list out those five and then have a
Citywide poll of some sort or an
engagement mechanism in which everyday
people are saying oh we want to be
involved with that this is they've also
done this in um oh I'm actually blanking
on how on how they when where they did
this but basically oh in Belgium I think
um on the deliberative Committees if I'm
not wrong um going back and forth where
the politicians say we're willing again
you go to the politicians we're willing
to work on these five issues and then
taking those five asking a the public of
these five what's the most important
then maybe going back to the experts
right there so there's a um I'm supposed
to be short so I'll just I'll stop there
but I think designing a democratic
mechanism to arrive at that and and
doing engagement with that rather than
there just being some topic that comes
like a UFO like the immediate thing if
there's not a good messenger is like who
chose this topic right I
think and so regretfully we are out of
time but thankfully this panel and the
entire conference today has been
recorded and you can find um information
about the conference contact details for
the presenters and the video clips on
the Yale isbs website under the
Democratic Innovations program I'd like
to take this opportunity to again thank
Yale isps Ellen Gerber Pam and Kira for
helping us organize this conference and
thank you so much to our panelists and
all participants
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah